[Music]
foreign
then for the Press preview it's our
first chance to see tomorrow's papers
and tonight so we'll be having a look at
the headlines with the senior associate
editor at the new Statesman Rachel
canliff and the political editor at the
sun Harry Cole great to see you there
spunk bank holiday Monday thanks for for
joining us this evening we'll chat in a
moment after we've had a look at those
headlines for you starting with the
Metro leading with the first official
picture of the King after his coronation
and his message to his people thank you
each and every one
it's tomorrow's daily Express with the
same picture and almost identical
headline
the times as well has that picture and
quote from the King
while the mail says Charles had a bust
up with Boris Johnson over government
plans to ship Asylum Seekers to Rwanda
while he was still Prince of Wales
the telegraph also pictures the king but
leads with a plea from prime minister
Rishi sunak for people not to go to
their GP with common ailments and go to
their local pharmacy instead to ease
pressure on doctors
the eye reports that MPS have called on
the major High Street Banks to pass on
the recent rises in interest rates to
Savers and not just borrowers it comes
with another rate rise expected this
week from the bank of England
while the Ft reveals that dividend
payouts from the country's big water
companies have doubled in the last year
despite the controversy over Rising
household bills and criticism about
discharging raw sewage into our
waterways
and staying with the subject of
household bills the mirror reports that
millions of families missed at least one
Bill's payment last month in the face of
what it calls unrelenting high prices
while the star carries words of warning
from what it calls a former cyber boffin
about the dangers to society posed by
artificial intelligence
uh don't forget you can scan the QR code
that you see on screen during the Press
preview check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you watch us
discussing them and Rachel and Harry are
here to do just that
um let's start shall we uh with the
coronation given that uh things have uh
ended today in terms of the celebrations
Rachel the front of the Daily Express
carrying uh this official photograph of
King Charles many of the front pages of
course carrying it as well we thank each
and every one of you who wrote in a open
letter to the nation Rachel it's a
pretty striking image isn't it what have
been your thoughts of this weekend
oh my goodness well today the focus has
very much been on the the volunteering
effort and I think that's a really
lovely touch we were not sure when uh we
knew there was going to be a correlation
there's going to be a bank holiday
there's going to be an extra one
obviously we got one for the The Queen's
funeral and to have that bank holiday
and to say it's a chance for people to
to give back to the local communities to
volunteer and look here's the prince and
princess of Wales and their children
doing just that at a local Scout Center
I think that's really lovely and that's
a sort of sign of how you can update
some of the uh trappings of monarchy and
some of the old traditions to to fit up
on Modern Age I have to say I'm not a
massive fan of the official portraits uh
I know it's all the photos maybe maybe
I'll get maybe I'll get used to it
um I just feel that there were more
striking ones of the ceremony itself
kind of the people the Grandeur of the
Abbey uh and you've got a sense of the
the process and actually was the the
process and all the different people
being involved in that ceremony that I
personally found really powerful looking
at that it looks a little bit like
someone dressing up to me but maybe
maybe I'll get used to it I don't know
well I suppose it is somebody dressing
up isn't it to us to a certain extent
um I'll probably be sent to the tower
Harry for saying that but what what do
you do you like the photo
I think what struck me about that Vedra
is is quite a stark contrast it is to
the official portrait of
um Elizabeth
um all those years ago wearing exactly
the same get up same Crown continuity or
uh The Works
um but that image of Elizabeth is so
striking because she's so young
um it's sort of almost like a sort of
post-war era hopefulness of this young
beautiful queen and I don't know
his majesty you know he's not he's not
as young he is you know the oldest
ground Monarch
um in history and we you could it really
does show in that in in that picture so
it's um it's different so it takes
getting used to but I think we've been
slightly um spoiled with imagery over
the last uh 96 hours so I'm probably
being just a little bit fussy in
panicity now
um just the just the scale and colors of
that of that ceremony at the weekend
I've only ever really seen it in black
and white or very grainy 1950s
photographs I think what the um what I
was unable to escape was just how much
gold there is and it's a pretty social
media rage pre-television age you can
imagine that ceremony and that parade
through London being pretty you know
striking and fantastic in a completely
different way whereas now I think we
slightly take it all for granted and it
risks perhaps some of it looking a
little bit silly because I think we've
been so sort of uh you know we're we've
been almost spoiled by it yeah it's a
very good point
um and uh something that uh was a cloud
over the day uh were these arrests and
and the Fallout from them are just
looking in the Metro their headline
coronation arrest tactics backed by the
PM after backlash
um Rachel uh the Met police today saying
that they've expressed uh regrets at
some of those arrests those six arrests
by members of uh Republic who have been
uh uh let go without any further um uh
uh issue
their bail conditions have all been
dropped
um but the Prime Minister standing by
the police what would you make of that
oh I don't think he really has a choice
I think it's very very unfortunate when
the public order bill was being debated
lots of people myself included pointed
out that it handed new powers to the
police including the power to arrest
people before they disrupted anything
just if the police thought they might be
disruptive or if they found items on
them that were hugely broad hugely vague
in specification that could be used for
things like lock-on well that's exactly
what happened here the police arrested
these individuals because they had uh
devices of them that the police at the
time said oh they could use that to lock
on to cause disruption no they were for
the placards but that the law is drafted
so broadly that they were able to to do
that I don't buy the Met regret either
because before the coronation they did a
very long Twitter thread where they said
tolerance would be low which I think is
very Sinister in a democratic country to
have the police going we're we're not
going to be tolerant of your peaceful
process there are all kinds of other
mishaps as well missteps arresting a
journalist who had a press card who was
covering a protest well that's not in
the law and the Met police should have
known that arresting volunteers of
Westminster Council who were handing out
rape alarms to vulnerable women as part
of a scheme that is actually endorsed by
the home office that's also not a good
look for them either especially after
the year that they've had and I just
feel as somebody who does believe in the
monarchy and does and does think that it
works for us and works for our country
it's it's not a good look when you have
people criticizing an unelected head of
state
to then be arrested for expressing that
view the point of living in a democratic
country is the peaceful protest is
allowed the Met clearly aired on the
side of any disruption is is true
disruption for us no thank you we'll
arrest you and ask questions later
clearly they they made a mistake and I
think we should be a little bit
concerned by that Harry
yeah I mean I think this needs to be
seen in in in a little bit of context
the the the threats from uh likes of
just up oil uh and Associated sort of
climate groups who have been openly
threatening to disrupt the disrupt the
um the process of the procession on on
Saturday you've then got to look at the
the balance of these things in that you
know there are 11 000 police officers
there are millions of people in London
the vast majority of the public support
please taking tougher action on
protesters but you know on the whole the
Met had done a very very good job you
know and that's why I think the PM was
in a bit of a tricky position today
because he was at the same praise it
that then come out at nine o'clock at
night on a bank holiday and said yeah we
did get it wrong on these these six
protesters it feels to me like that I
mean they're not good that's going to
dominate the the the the debate and the
discussion
um it feels like once again the Met like
just it's one step forward two steps
back with them at the moment and it
doesn't really seem to be able to to
sort of catch a break and does that
deservedly have a thorough and utter
kicking and continue to get that
throughout this year about the handling
of some of their offices but you know
there's a new management in charge and
yet again they're never far from the
headlines and there are there's a
growing number of people within
government within you know within sort
of policing who do think the Met is too
big it's too worldly it is you know is
it really fit for purpose and all this
is going to do is add weight to that
argument but perhaps the time has come
to break up that police Falls because
should they be trying to do everything
be that these vast scale events like
this anti-terrorism normal day-to-day
crime maybe it's time to split it up
okay
um well as the papers are reminding us
uh the the fun and festivities of the
weekend uh have come to an end and it's
back to Earth with a bump cost of living
of course Rising bills front of the Ft
Rachel water company dividends double to
1.4 billion pounds
pages of of all of the new paper you
know all that raw sewage that's being
dumped in our rivers and our seas and
all the water companies going oh there's
nothing we can do the infrastructure is
crumbling well somehow they're paying
out dividends worth billions uh and uh
the it's all masked by some sort of
Byzantine very complicated system
because there are the internal dividends
that they don't have to declare are they
external dividends going to shareholders
it's all very murky off what are looking
into it there's a line in that ft story
that says that by 2025 off what will
have the power to question and indeed
block dividends if they if they don't
think the companies should be paying
them out why 2025 what has been going on
the water companies 30 years ago when
they were privatized didn't have any
debt now they have debts of of hundreds
of of millions they're spending the same
amount on infrastructure and investment
repair as they did then so the
investment hasn't gone into our
infrastructure and our Water Systems
bills are going up we've got raw sewage
being dumped in the sea and yet all this
money is going somewhere where is it
going nobody knows and the front of the
mirror on a on a similar theme really
just how difficult life is for so many
uh people while some of these companies
are making a lot of money
um high prices are unrelenting with two
million people missing at least one bill
last month
I mean it feels a bit of a sort of um
coronation hangover you know back to
back to work tomorrow for the rest of
the country and back to the realities of
the world and don't forget it was only
last Thursday that
um that the the government took a hefty
kicking at the ballot boxes we haven't
really had the proper Fallout from that
yet because obviously the count went
late into Friday and then everyone went
into coronation fever so MPS returning
back to the commons um tomorrow I
suspect will we have fairly heaving in
trades on this sort of things the lip
Dems made a big issue of um of water
companies and sewage and rivers in their
local election campaigns which saw them
make headways very affluent parts of the
country and the cost of living crisis
poll we did last week for the sun you
know it continues to be soaring prices
and inflation continue to be the number
one issue for voters that's not going to
go away and and anytime soon and
inflation does seem to be sticky you
know the the bank of England and the obr
and whatnot and other three letter uh
types have all made these vast
predictions that it's going to be down
to single digits soon and down to even
back two percent by the end of next year
uh it doesn't feel like that at the
moment and the next round of inflation
numbers you know if they continue need
to be above 10 I think you know this
this political headache for the
government is not going to be fixed in
any way yeah we're talking more about
that uh after the break thank you both
for the moment uh coming up in a couple
of minutes the eye says MPS have called
on banks to pass on the recent rise is
in interest rates to Savers and not just
borrowers discussing that uh shortly
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Press preview where
Rachel and Harry are still with us front
page of the eye Harry
um banks are being told that they're
cashing in and taking advantage of
Savers according to one that treasury
Committee Member talking to the eye and
Banks being asked to pass on higher
interest rates
yeah I think they put this one down in a
in a sort of more in Hope than optimism
uh folder obviously interest rates look
set to go as we were just discussing
before the break with inflation
remaining is doublingly high pressure on
the bank to keep rates high and really
the economy is shaping up to be the
defining issue of the net collection it
kind of always is but perhaps sometimes
to a lesser extent than in other fights
and it feels like there's a sort of
scrambling round in government and
there's a lot of anger aimed at Andrew
Bailey in the bank for how they've
handled the last 18 months and and that
inflation Target of 2.5 which seems like
a pipe dream now and this sort of
strikes me a little bit as yet another
sort of you know desperate attempt to
try and you know ease the pain but one
I'm not sure is going to be that
successful yeah it's an interesting
statistic Rachel um in the eye in
October 2008 when the base rate was last
at four and a half percent the best
flexible accounts paid 6.6 percent the
best saving rates today 3.7 percent
it's always interesting when when
interest rates go up the time it takes
for mortgage rates or for loan interest
rates to increase is a nanoseconds the
time it takes for interest rates on
Savers accounts to to rise is weeks
months possibly years and uh it was the
same with petrol it was the same when
fuel Duty was cutting and did that
saving make it to the motorist at the
petrol pump somehow it didn't it's the
same with food inflation uh wholesale
food prices are coming down at the
moment you won't see it at the
supermarket those prices are staying
stubbornly high so I think there are
lots of areas of of our economy where
that those prices are not getting
through to consumers in a positive way
and all of the risk all of the pain is
being taken by individuals while
businesses manage to protect their
profit margins okay front of the
telegraph Harry that picture again of
the king but the story their main uh the
main story there is all about ending
this 8 A.M GP phone call Lottery and
they're going with the angle that
patients are going to be able to get
prescriptions from pharmacies without
seeing a doctor first
yeah so day two of uh sunac sort of
Health blitz so as we were saying
coronation's over now back to the back
to the five pledges uh which I hope
you're not gonna ask me to name what
they are because I can't remember them
but one of them is getting Hospital
waiting lists down and part of that in
tomorrow is a big announcement for the
PM he's actually written for the sun
tomorrow all about this is that
um for a host of things like earache
coughs and sneezes uh blood tests um
getting the contraceptive pill you don't
have to see you're not gonna have to see
a GP anymore you're gonna even do it at
a high street chemist now this kind of
you know it's quite a European model
like it's it it's kind of baffling that
lots of these things antibiotics do you
need for an earache you need to go and
see a doctor anyway about boosting
Pharmacists and um governments
expectations this means that they can
save around 2 million um GP appointments
every year to free up that um that sort
of backlogging GPS which will hopefully
then trickle down into uh to easing some
of the pressure on A's and hospitals and
get the system get the system moving if
that makes sense uh it does make sense
uh Rachel your thoughts on these uh
these reforms to these GPS pressures
well anything that we can do to to ease
the pressures with GPS or a e I think we
should seriously look into the idea of
Pharmacists prescribing antibiotics
comes up every couple of months it seems
and has done for very many years and the
argument against that is that antibiotic
resistance is a massive threat to Modern
Healthcare as we know it and it's
something that we should be very very
careful about
um the other issue is that a lot of the
time people who are going to see their
GP have issues that are not necessarily
health related but are to do with the
lack of Community Support sort of the
elderly our social care crisis there are
all kinds of interlocking issues there
it's not quite as simple as just have
somebody else give you the medicine that
you need but I do think if we're going
to solve this crisis we need to be
looking holistically at all aspects of
our Healthcare System and obviously
pharmacies are a key part of that it's
slightly challenging that there are now
fewer pharmacies and a lot of them are
shutting down and so even the the the
part of the healthcare system that this
pressure is meant to be eased by passing
people onto that looks like it could be
facing serious challenges as well sadly
yeah the Association of Independent
multiple pharmacists saying a funding
shortfall of 1.1 billion pounds has left
many chemists severely struggling with
cash flow problems um and let's finish
off uh with a story that appears in the
paper almost Daily Now doesn't it Harry
Ai and people's concerns about Ai and
where it's all going and how fast things
are moving on the front of the The Daily
Star they take a fairly jokey angle with
it but it is a serious issue
yeah I think this is I can't see the
tiny print on there but I'm guessing
this is Kieran Martin the former boss of
um gchq backed um cyber security Center
who was out and about on the radio
um at the weekend just cooling time for
this the you know when the The Godfather
of AI the the person who's one of the
most biggest Pioneers in all this is
sort of had a sort of Manhattan Project
approach to it and said if they had
their time again would they have done it
perhaps not
um you've got Elon Musk saying things
need to be things need to you know calm
down there was a think tank last week I
think it was onward I think that said
Britain is being left behind in the AI
race so it is exploded as with chat gbt
sort of arrivals exploded into a debate
it is a massively important debate to be
had and even if the Daily Star I've
obviously taken the Daily Star attitude
to it and it's better to be having it in
some form than than none at all I have
to say the one thing that AI is so far
not being able to do is write newspaper
headlines we tried to get them to we
tried to get one of the programs to
recreate famous songs stories as their
headlines and they were they were
disastrous so it won't be long Harry it
won't be long it's around the corner
Rachel won very quick thought 10 seconds
uh there are some guys who've written an
app that will talk to women on dating
sites using a chat bot without telling
them that's what they're talking to they
think that's going to make dating better
and for the women who are talking to
this chatbot rather than the men who are
using it to try and date women maybe it
will oh crikey okay well listen thank
you very much for joining us good luck
in the week ahead and we'll speak again
soon we're going to finish with a quick
look at the weather